- Limoilou, 15 juin dernier.
La scène a un air de déjà-vu.
Le Québec est secoué par
un 13e féminicide en 2021.
Derrière la tragédie, il y a
une mère tuée et trois enfants
dans le deuil.
CATHERINE GENOIS,
fille de Nathalie Piché
- C'est quelque chose que
je vais probablement jamais
accepter. Je vais arrêter.
Je vais vivre avec, mais,
t'sais, jamais de me vie je vais
accepter ça. Ça va toujours
me faire autant de mal,
je pense.
- Catherine Genois a vécu avec
sa mère, Nathalie Piché,
et celui qui allait être accusé
de l'avoir tuée, Nourredine
Mimouni. Elle a vu leur histoire
d'amour devenu toxique,
violente, au point de devenir
scène de meurtre.
- C'était beaucoup de jalousie,
de possession, t'sais, puis
c'était pas une belle relation.
Ma mère, elle se racrochait
aux beaux petits moment
qu'il y avait de temps en temps.
Mais en général, c'était rien
de... Rien d'intéressant pour
elle puis je lui ai toujours
fait comprendre.
- La jeune fille avait 19 ans
lorsqu'elle partageait
leur logement. Les signes
de discorde ne manquaient pas
entre sa mère et Mimouni.
- Le soir, ma mère souvent,
elle venait s'asseoir avec moi
dans ma chambre puis j'ai
souvent remarqué qu'elle avait
dee marques sur les jambes,
dans le cou, sur les bras.
Puis quand je lui en parlais,
bien, elle me disait qu'ils
jouaient, t'sais, que c'était
juste pour jouer que t'sais,
ils jouaient "rough" un petit
peu, là.
- La violence, c'est souvent
une façon de reprendre
le contrôle sur une situation.
De tuer, c'est un contrôle
ultime.
- Cette tendance à justifier
l'inacceptable, Katia De
Pokomandy-Morin l'a souvent
observée.
KATIA DE POKOMANDY-MORIN,
dg, YWCA Québec
- Les victimes de violences
conjugales ont tendance
à se faire isoler
par le conjoint dans beaucoup
de situations, à s'isoler aussi
d'elle-même parce que c'est pas
"le fun", hein, c'est pas
"le fun" quand on se rend compte
qu'on vit de la violence
de le dire, de le nommer
à ses proches.
- Pourtant, des ressources
existent au Québec,
des ressources qui brisent
l'isolement et qui sauvent
des vies.
LOUISE RIENDEAU, coresponsable,
Hébergements pour femmes
- Toutes les femmes ont pas à
quitter leur maison, à aller
dans une maison d'hébergement,
mais toutes peuvent recevoir
de l'aide au téléphone
ou par des rendez-vous
en personne. Et je pense
que c'est le premier pas.
- Si Catherine Genois a décidé
de parler, c'est pour inciter
les femmes à demander de l'aide
avant de subir le même sort
que sa mère.
- Il y a un déclic qu'il faut
qu'il se fasse dans la tête
des femmes qu'il faut qu'on
apprenne à s'aimer plus
qu'on les aime eux. Puis il faut
que vous vous dîtes qu'un homme
qui vous aime vraiment va jamais
penser une seconde à lever
la main sur vous ou vous faire
du mal.
- Ici Sébastien Tanguay,
Radio-Canada,